hey guys this is ben from lucky cat
we are here and we are going to show you
how to make an amazing barbecue sauce
it's going to be something you can use
with chicken you can use it with fish
we're going to do a pork rib dish it
also works really well with game
especially now starting with the game
season so let's get to the sauce
our main ingredient for the sauce or the
hero is cumin
so we've got some roasted cumin seeds
which is just ground down and we've got
some roasted black peppercorns
so we're going to just put them into the
present water and just give it another
quick bash
just to break them down a little bit
more super important to toast
your seeds before or spices before you
grind them because it releases a lot of
the oil softens them up a little bit
makes them more easy to
break down it's going to go it looks
like quite a lot but
it's going to be fine then to that we're
going to add the rest of the ingredients
we've got some dried
korean chili flakes we've got some
vanilla sugar
there's some like awesome soft brown
sugar if you haven't got that
um worcestershire sauce very hard to say
worcestershire sauce
uh we've got some ketchup which we make
right now at the end of the summer with
some beautiful tomatoes cider vinegar
so it's going to be nice and sharp we've
got sweet sour spicy thing going on
two more ingredients are this is our
smoked sriracha sauce which we've made
with our friends over at eaton alive
down in south london so you can use
normal sriracha if you haven't got the
smoked or you're not
got that available to you and the secret
ingredient is this
looks a bit gross but it is a combo
extract so like kombudaki so it's quite
a
quite a niche ingredient but if you can
get it it works super well it just adds
a really delicious
flavor to the sauce so we're going to do
is just give it a really good mix
and then we're going to pop it onto the
fire and bring it up to the boil and
we're just going to simmer it for about
about 10 or 15 minutes just so that it
thickens up slightly you don't want it
too thick so you don't want it to be
like ketchup
um but you want to have it just so you
can start to glaze lacquer up the meat
or fish that you're cooking so we'll
just pop that on the stove now
and that's it and then we're going to
leave it there for about 10 minutes let
it come to the simmer for about 15 and
then we're ready to go
[Music]
okay so that's our sauce so basically we
just brought it to the boil um you need
to get brains into the boil so
everything kind of comes together and as
a rolling boil starts everything starts
to emulsify together so you've got all
those different liquids and sugars and
spices in there you want it all to
become like a beautiful
uh if you look now you see it's a really
nice shiny
glaze it's quite nice and thick as well
so what we've done is we're just
roasting these
pork ribs over the barbecue we smoked
them as well but if you haven't got a
smoker it's
completely fine um we're just roasting
and basically rendering out all the fat
crisping up the meat slightly and then
we're just gonna keep basting this
beautiful sauce
[Music]
so we're just gonna finish on the grill
plenty of glaze so
if you're going to cook a chicken for
example you wouldn't pre-cook the
chicken and reheat it you'd have it um
just nicely slowly going over the fire
slowly over the grill that's why it
works really nicely with game birds so
quail
we're going gonna do it with grouse soon
as we get the first grouse in just
really gently grilled
and they cook quite quickly so that's
kind of what we're looking for
so while it's cooking really really
important just keep basting it and
basically i'm basing it
if you see any like barbecue guys from
america they normally have a mop and a
bucket and that's how much sauce they're
putting on so they're just
basting on there basically when they're
basting on this it's just the meat
the fats coming out of the meat and then
the replacement of the fat the sauce is
going in there it's gonna be really
sticky and beautiful and delicious
so you can see we've got that beautiful
char color all that sugar and all that
caramel is just
sticking onto the ribs now we're just
going to give it one final glaze
right now and then we're going to hit it
now with some
loads of roasted spices
so now we're just going to finish it
with some roasted spices
so in here i've got a lucky sashimi
pepper so a mix of seven spices
chili coriander seeds and ground shiso
and then we also
put some tomatoes dehydrated tomato
powders in there as well
and some sesame seeds so it gives it a
really beautiful flavor and then we've
got
the spices that we used for the sauce
we've got some toasted cumin
we've got some roasted coriander seeds
and then we've also got a little bit
more of the chili
and black pepper and white peppercorns
that's going to go on top
and then we basically just serve a dish
straight onto
a nice clean tray and then we serve it
with a little bit more of the barbecue
sauce
and we serve it with lime and that is
our
cumin spiced barbecue ribs
[Music]
you